some people in low-risk demographics do
not want to get
the hastily developed covid vaccine
because
they know that statistically speaking
the virus does not pose a great danger
to them
and the libs are very very upset about
this
but they have now come across what they
believe
will be a sure-fire way to convince all
of these people
to get the vaccine free fries when you
get vaccinated
um i got vaccinated
you're saying i could get this a
delicious fries
why am i but there's also a burger
element to this
let me let me check with bill needhardt
is it too early in the day to eat a
birthday
no this could be breakfast okay
i want you to look at this and think
about don't make me watch again
no some people love hamburgers some
don't really want to respect
all ways of life but if this is
appealing to you just think of this when
you think of vaccination
oxidation
i'm getting a very good feeling
about vaccination right this moment if
if that is what i think of when i think
of vaccination i'm never getting any
vaccinations again
i regret getting the polio vaccination
if that is what i have to think of
the the argument is hey you animals
hey let us stick you with this needle
and we'll give you more slop
yeah you like slop don't you you filthy
animals you gluttons
yeah get the burger that may that made
me at least
99.7 less likely to get the vaccine
what the libs are trying to create is an
elaborate system
of carrots and sticks to get us to do
what they want us to do
and you've seen the carrot
the carrot is is the cheeseburger bill
de blasio
that that disgusting glutton just
letting
juice drip down his face on television
because he thinks that's going to entice
us
that's the carrot and then the stick
is joe biden who tweeted out yesterday
quote
the rule is now simple get vaccinated
or wear a mask until you do the choice
is yours
no and no i think i'm not
vaccinated i don't have any plans to get
vaccinated anytime soon and i'm not
wearing a mask i'm not wearing a mask
basically anywhere the only place they
make me wear a mask and i have no way
around it
is on airplanes because you're in that
little tin can
and they'll arrest you if you don't
otherwise i ain't doing it ain't wearing
a mask
hugging people shaking hands i'm like
two seconds away from just french
kissing people on the street
because that is how unafraid i am of
this thing
nope not so fast you know you know what
you got to do
come on don't make me say it you got to
ring the bell
you got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe you gotta like that is how
you will get notifications so that i can
see you on the next
[Music]
video
you